okay 210 let's get rolling uh welcome to
deep unsupervised learning first
lecture let's start with the instructor
team I'm Peter Beal I'm Professor
teaching the course and we have three
co-instructors with me here maybe three
of you can briefly stand up maybe even
here in front of the camera also and do
a quick self intro um yeah Philip why
you go first then Kevin then
Wilson um yeah hi everyone my name is
Phillip I'm a PhD student uh with
Professor Peter be um and I work on a
variety of different topics but largely
with real world robot learning um
Crossing reinforcement learning
imitation learning and supervised
learning so yeah hope we'll have a great
semester thanks
pH yeah everyone I'm Kevin also a fish
with uh Peter and Sergey and um yeah I
work kind of on reinforcement learning
algorithms and generative modeling which
we'll talk about in the class great
thanks
K yeah hey everyone I'm also one of
Peter's PC students and I do research in
generative models more specifically
stuff with like video and language
generation you actually took the classes
underground here I yeah I took the class
and I was a TA the semester after yeah
but it's been it's been a long time
since been a while last time we T the
class was uh 2020 so 4 years ago it's
pretty interesting because I was looking
at the slides from four years ago and I
saw I put a lot of motivation in there
and especially 5 years ago a lot of
motivation why people should study deep
UNS supervised learning because I
thought people weren't interested enough
in deep un survice learning should
really motivate them and now I feel like
I need to do the opposite uh or maybe
slightly more precisely um I want to
make sure in this lecture to make clear
what we are actually planning to do in
this class because becoming so popular
that in principle you could do a million
different things in a deep un survis
learning class and so I want to make
sure you know what we are going to do
here rather than maybe what you imagine
we could be
doing so couple of logistics
communication uh there's a website
that's the URL
um went up I think
yesterday um we should be putting all
information up there that's needed for
the class we'll put uh typically the
slides there before lecture not today
it's the first lecture it's always bit
of a transition period when the semester
starts but go starting next week we plan
to put up the slides before lecture uh
so you can take notes on them if you
want or look at them a little bit ahead
of time um has the schedule
everything if you see anything that
seems off let us know um could be that
there's still a little typo here or
there uh just let us know some
announcements uh we use Ed for
communication I've actually never used
it um it's the first time I'm going to
be using it but it seems the the
standard thing to use for Berkeley
classes currently so I'm excited to to
be using it um please start there if you
have questions because then others can
see your questions help answer them
instead of us getting separate questions
from everybody who might then the
questions might have a lot of
overlap if you're by the way registered
or on the wait list we already put you
into the forum for this class if you are
neither then you have to put yourself in
so Ed is preferred if you have questions
for us um uh just to be clear not during
lecture I mean like during lecture just
raise your hand ask questions that way
but outside the lecture start there if
you have rather than email but if it's
something you think that's more suitable
for email feel free to email the staff
list or if you think it's specific to
any one of us email just us individually
um but try to use Ed if
possible office hours will start next
week um for for me it'll be after
lecture so lecture is 2: to 5: on
Thursdays um it's a long slot 3 hours
most lectures are not that long we'll
take a pretty big break in the middle 15
20 minute break um we'll even have
snacks to uh have like reinforcements
for the second half of of lecture um and
that's actually quite deliberate I think
one of the big things you can get out of
the class is to get to know other
students in the class who working on
similar topics you can exchange ideas
come up with new ideas together and I
think having the long lecture slot with
a break in the Middle where you get to
hang out talk to each other can be very
good for that
purpose I'll do my office hours right
after class so that'll be a very long
stretch if you stick around for that uh
it'll be 5 to six um Wilson Kevin and uh
Phillip will uh announce their office
hours sometime next week um we still
figure out how to do it we might have
some office hours or maybe one ta is in
charge of one homework and then has all
the office hours leading up to that
homework due time or maybe we'll have
regular like weekly office hours we're
still sorting that
out so for homework by the way ta office
ours are the best venue even though I'd
love to be able to help you with
homework like I dream every every every
winter break I dream of a semester where
I actually have the time to work through
the homework myself and uh then be able
to help you the reality is like I just
can't like I don't know the details well
enough but these three will so for
homework specific questions go to them
um for anything else all of us uh should
be able to help you um and I think for a
lot of us one of the favorite things is
to talk with you about your projects
what you are doing research on how you
think it might connect with things in
the course and how things in the course
can help you be more effective in
whatever you are doing research-wise or
maybe your research is squarely and UNS
supervised learning and is directly
feeding off the
course um admission to the course it's a
bit of a challenge that there is more
demand than there there is uh spots and
I think that's just going to be the
reality some people are not going to get
in um what we'll do to Nodge things
towards uh a best possible situation is
people who don't have a strong homework
one or no homework one at all submitted
we'll ask uh the register's office to
drop them out of the class now obviously
if something really crazy comes up and
you can't do homework one because there
some external circumstances reach out to
us and let us know we can think about it
but to us that's just a sign if you're
either not suitable for the class or you
just don't care enough about the class
to submit a strong homework will drop
you and we'll let people in from the
wait list also if just after today if
you register for the class and you
realize oh my God I thought it's going
to be what all these VCS talk about with
generative AI we're going to be like the
next big startup out of this class it's
not exactly targeted that way um so then
maybe also drop out of the class make
room for others could be many reasons
you think the class is not for you after
today's lecture don't don't wait till
the drop deadline because that's
inconvenient for for everybody else just
drop when you know you're going to
drop even if you don't make it into
class you're welcome to audit you're
welcome to submit homework uh that
that's all good you just won't get the
credit for having taking the
class um and as we move people into the
class um it could be undergrads could be
good fits for the class PhD students I
mean it's really more about what you
know what you're capable of than exactly
what degre you're pursuing typically phg
students with more natural fits but not
always so we'll see what happens any
questions about
registration yes are there any like
quantifiable like cut offs for what a
strong homework one means and also how
does this relate to whether you're like
fully registered versus weight listed
versus not so we'll grade everybody's
submission whether you're weight listed
or not even weight listed or you are
registered if you submit your home
homework will graded um then what is
strong homework one is the way we design
them is essentially they should be
solvable for somebody who can who's
taking the class it's not something
where like a strong homework is like
solving half the homework a strong
homework means that you essentially
solve everything that doesn't mean it
can be a beauty mistake here or there
but it can be that there's just a whole
part of the homework that you didn't do
um we're also here to help you I mean we
want you to learn it's not that you need
to be able to do this without any help
come to office hour ask question
questions but if you use all the
resources available and all the time
you're willing to commit to it and then
end up having big parts of your homework
just in one substantial section that's
just blank or completely off then likely
we would drop you if we see that there
are many people on the weight list to
have much stronger uh submissions um
think of it like you know maybe in in
numbers let's say you got to score 90%
or something on homework one but don't
worry if you have 98 or 99 we're not
going to rank people and then like be
like okay think the exact ranking but
roughly 90% as a threshold you're
good yes what should we expect as the
deadline for homework form H coming up
in a moment great question yeah I have a
slide on on all the
deadlines
okay um let me tell a bit about the
syllabus today's intro we're not going
to cover actual uh materials today we're
going to cover motivation for the class
why this class might be worth taking um
and we will cover some Logistics um but
then next week we'll start diving in
with autoaggressive models which is the
first type of model we'll cover the week
after we'll do flow models then we'll do
latent variable models then we'll do
Gans uh SL implicit models and then
we'll do diffusion models and final
project discussion so those will be in
some sense the five main types of models
that we'll cover um from there we'll
look at other types of learning uh so
five main generative models then we'll
look at self supervised learning
non-generative representation learning
we'll look at strength and weaknesses of
everything covered so far because part
of what's hard about the field I would
say is that it's a bit disjoint it's not
so easy to directly necessarily compare
a vae with an autoaggressive model there
are pros and cons to them the field
hasn't fully converged maybe we'll never
conversion on just one thing clearly
language is more conversed onto
autoaggressive and vision is more
converged onto um diffusion models right
now but this this can change over time
in fact last time we taught the course
diffusion models didn't exist um we
still had to invent them later that
semester semi-supervised learning unised
distribution alignment these are things
that are somehow not as hot topics these
days but I think they're very important
and I think part part of what the
beauties of this class by the way same
for flow models is that we have the time
to cover some things that are less hot
today but maybe with some Innovation can
become the next breakthrough if you find
the right
Innovation compression compression is
not typically a machine learning topic
but it turns out everything unsupervised
learning is effectively tied back to
compression because the core hypothesis
in unsurprised learning is that you're
modeling data and what does it mean to
model data well what does it mean to do
comp impression is the same thing it's
finding the patterns in the data and
based on that representing it in a more
compact way in machine learning we don't
just care about compact we want it to be
semantically meaningful so there's a
little bit of an extra twist to the
notion of compression there but it's
very very
related spring break week no lecture uh
naturally then we'll do language models
a dedicated lecture obviously some
things will come back there from earlier
language models are autoaggressive
models large so some things will come
back but we'll dive much deeper into
specifics of language models then we'll
have a
midterm um I think I have a separate
slide on that so I'll wait for that to
say more about that um we'll do
multimodal models and video generation
that lecture I'll definitely remind you
will be in a different location we'll be
in the auditorium upstairs slightly
bigger room um then we'll have electron
AI for science uh and we'll have
representation learning for
reinforcement learning note that these
two lectures are in the same week so
there's going to be a Thursday and a
Friday lecture a pretty wild week cuz
you have like three hours on Thursday
another three hours on Friday um but we
won't have a lecture the next week so
the last week of the normal semester the
one be a lecture I moved it Forward onto
the Friday before that um week 15 no
lecture RR week then week 16 your final
project reports will be due and video
presentation submission so we'll take
instead of doing an inclass sequence of
presentations which I found at the end
of the semester students are so busy and
it's hard to find a time to attend the
other students presentations so it's
often like students just jumping in
doing their presentation jumping back
out get to study for their final or
another project we're just going to take
submissions we'll watch the videos but
we're going to share the videos unless
there's a specific reason you don't want
your videos shared we'll share them
internally with the class so anybody
who's interested in a topic can go watch
the video present a on that topic that
was done in the
class any questions on the schedule yeah
lecture 13 be in the same classroom at
the same time as usual I don't know yet
I've put in a request for for a room but
I haven't heard back yet um yeah very
good question and good reminder but it
is on my to-do list to to sort it out I
asked them two days ago and it's
probably a busy beginning of semester um
for them to
respond nothing thing about lectures
they're all recorded so there a Camtasia
recording running here which sees
whoever is standing in front of the
laptop and Records the screen can't
guarantee it works out every time
sometimes these things crash and then
there's no proper recording but
hopefully usually it works out and then
we'll put these
online yeah we do have a lecture on the
same day as the midterm yes so the
midterm will be very short I'll say more
about that
soon homework we'll have homework one go
out next week Thursday due 13 days later
then 14 days after that um homework two
will go out so essentially every two
weeks a homework will go out if you look
at previous offering what you see has
changed that there's right now no
homework and flow models if you care
about them you want to learn more about
them and do a homework on them you can
go to the 2020 website do the homework
from there for your own good not not for
the class um I think it's still
interesting but we only want to give you
four homeworks and we think right now
it's better to give you a homework on
diffusion models rather than flow models
just the way things are shaping up but
again these things can change you could
come back here a year from now and say
what a big mistake you should really
have done flow models way more important
um hard to predict but this is what
we're going to
do so that puts us roughly halfway to
semester and then the idea is that from
there a lot of your time outside of
class is spent on your final project for
homework you can discuss things uh but
you need to write your own code and make
your own
submission um you can be late with a
late policy but not too much at most
four days um why do we have the postive
at most four days logistically
essentially we want to be able to get
started on grading is one two we think
you can learn a lot from looking at
Solutions but you learn more if not a
lot of time has passed before you get to
see the solutions so after 4 days we
will release Solutions you can look at
those learn from that and hopefully
that's a good learning experience but at
the same time you know that means you
can submit after those four days again
if there are really exceptional
circumstances always you know don't be
afraid to reach out we can think about
it um but uh that's the standard model
we're going to
use so the midterm we have a midterm
during lecture the beginning of lecture
on April
11th
um I think in the end what's most
important is what you learn from from
the class what you take away and what
hopefully you put in your final project
along the way but the reason I like to
do a midterm is because it gives you an
opportunity to be forced to really study
the materials um you're all so busy and
if nobody forces you to study the
materials probably you just have
something else fighting for your time
and winning out um it's not meant to be
excruciating or to be weeding you out in
any way or other um is going to be
topics covered to the week before we
will provide a document with questions
and answers so essentially we will go
through the lecture slides pick the most
important derivations according to us
write a question let's say derive the
rational lower Bound for a vae and then
put the answer below it and you'll have
anywhere 10 to 20 pages of that kind of
material and then when the midterm comes
we'll ask you two or three of those um
obviously if you fail to study two or
three of them you might do pretty poorly
but hopefully since only 10 to 20 Pages
you have to study it should be easy to
just study everything uh and it's upon
us to make sure that these are the 10 to
20 most important things from the class
you can principle memorize it I don't
think that's the best way to study it
ideally you understand it and that way
are able to rederive it but you know
nobody is stopping you from from
memorizing it either and often
memorizing can help you understand uh
it's kind of an inter process in fact
language models just kind of you know
memorize and then understand so it's uh
it's just what you're supposed to do I
guess okay any questions about the
midterm all right
um final project uh scope IDE you
explore and push the boundaries in
unsupervised learning uh there will be a
proposal could be a proposal plus
evaluation of new algorithms
architectures investig investigation of
application of unsupervised learning
benchmarking unsupervised learning could
be something related to compression
studying synergies between unsupervised
learning and other types of learning and
so forth um pretty broad what's
acceptable but it really has to involve
the topics in the
class ideally it could be the foundation
for a future conference paper there's no
expectation that by the time you submit
the final project report that it's
already at the level of a conference
paper but hopefully maybe there's like
the initial experiments that show the
promise that this could really become a
conference paper with an extra push that
you put behind
it um we actually encourage you to come
up with your own idea if you can it'll
likely be more original because you have
your own background your own knowledge
that's different from ours
um that said um we're also happy to
brainstorm ideas together um and often
going back and forth can also lead to
new things that neither one of us would
come up with uh
individually so the main reason I
started teaching this class five years
ago was for these projects I wanted more
onar learning projects to happen at
Berkeley um some really good ones have
happened um one that um uh sticks with
me uh is Roshan raal uh student in the
first offering of the class did a
project on sequence modeling for biology
uh wrote one of the first papers on
essentially protein property prediction
based on pre-training on just sequence
modeling um released a tape Benchmark as
a nervs paper for that is all before
before Alpha fold um and from there
actually went to the Facebook sleta um
bio uh AI group and since then that team
has left meta and has started a company
that's essentially trying to build the
foundation models for bio for for the
future so that would be a great
trajectory any one of you go on that
trajectory love it I mean there's many
other great trajectories but something
that that is really um try to do
something exciting um if something
doesn't work but you have a lot of um
evidence that you try things that are
meaningful and didn't work that's more
interesting to me at least than if you
did something pretty boring and yeah it
worked but it was kind of boring and it
was kind of of you know kind of too
close to what other people have done so
try try to pick
something exciting and surprising if it
works
out
timeline project proposals due February
28th so you have a bit of time um you'll
put that in a Google doc so we can
easily give you feedback about a week
later um we will have iterated with you
in that Google doc and hopefully have
arrived at a project proposal that we're
all happy
with um then a three-page milestone is
due in April we'll also do Google doc
for ease of feedback um the idea here is
that it forces you to get started it's
very easy to wait till the end of the
semester if there's nothing forcing you
to get started earlier so you'll have to
start about a month and a half before
the end of the semester or even a bit
earlier to get something in there it
doesn't need to be anywhere near final
um but you should have some results some
initial investigations that you can
report
on May 10th everything will be do I
believe I'd have to check but I think
that is the the Friday of finals week
um grading Logistics 60% homework 10%
midterm 30% final project
um that's yeah and then the the letter
grades there's something on the website
that says what the letter grade is based
on the grades that you get um but I
believe it's probably like 90% and above
is an A and then from there every 5% it
loses uh a partial letter
grade do you need to attend class um no
hard requirement um obviously there's
not enough seats so it could be even be
uncomfortable to sit on the on the floor
for 3 hours um but I would say it's
highly
recommended um and it goes back to the
opportunity to learn from each other as
I said in the beginning of lecture we'll
have pretty large break right in the
middle good opportunity to learn from
each other and often new projects arise
from that uh actually Roshan's project
that I mentioned he got to know some of
the students that he did that with in
the class there were bio students taking
the the class he was a CS student and
then they start working on it
together only the third offering of the
course so some rough edges along the way
bear with us give feedback if there's
something you think that might be better
done a different way let us know that
doesn't mean we can always get around
doing it but we'll take notes and what
we can do we will do
okay so that's Logistics any questions
about logistics before we start with
more content in the
back yeah so we're trying to record
Camtasia is running right now which is a
screen capturing software um which can
capture at higher resolution for the
screen than let's say Zoom would um
we'll try every time maybe sometimes it
crashes and it doesn't work but
hopefully every time we have a recording
yes and then we'll hopefully post it uh
later that
evening or a couple more questions yes
are the final projects completely
independent or oh good question up to
three people I would recommend forming
teams of two or three because often when
there is more than one of you you have
more of a back and forth on ideas and
you can arrive at more interesting
things uh we do expect a little bit of a
linear scaling so if there's two or
three of you you're supposed to have a
more substantial achievement in your
project than when there's only one of
you Yes actually question
find
and yeah so we will um link the website
uh from The Forum the Ed Forum later
today so then you can find find the
website where all the materials will be
posted for submitting homework um I
guess we'll sort that out when we
release the first homework so by the
time it comes out next week we'll
hopefully have uh set up the way to
receive your homework also thank
you yes for under should we fill out a
form or just in the first
one um just turn in the first homework
and we'll take things from
there
all right so let's switch from Logistics
to content what is deep unsupervised
learning it's about capturing Rich
patterns in raw data with deep networks
in a label-free
way the label free part really matters
it's the original motivation for UNS
supervised learning because labeling is
time consuming and hence it's not nice
if you don't have to do it um but
there's actually additional motivations
Beyond it being label free which we'll
get to
soon there's kind of two sub areas in
unsupervised learning there is
generative models which try to recreate
the raw data distribution and there is
cell supervised learning which tend to
be puzzle tasks you have your data and
you remove some part of the data or some
view of the data in some way or other
and then it's supposed to fill it back
in if you can fill that back in then
presum you understand something about
the data um generative
models recreate the raw data
distribution there's a lot of talk about
generative Ai and I was thinking like
how how would I really Define what we're
trying to cover in this course for the
generative AI part and the way I think
of it
is it's still neural Nets right it's
it's still a neural net you you're
outputting you have an input you
generate an output even a generative
model is a NE Network and it looks a lot
like supervised learning in many cases
so what what's really different about it
um the way I think of it as being
different is that in a lot of the
typical work in supervised learning
there's a very clear deterministic
solution in that you have an image and
there's a clear label that needs to be
assigned to it cat or dog or you have a
self-driving car scene and every pixel
needs to be Street pavement versus
pedestrian and so forth and so the
output is in some sense deterministic
what you're supposed to do whereas in
generative models we're trying to model
pretty complex output distributions on
the neural network and that's actually
hard to do to model complicated
distributions and that's why there's
actually five different lectures each
three-hour lectures covering five
different ways of covering effectively
complex distributions with neural
networks and so that's the way I would
think about it is generative models at
least in this class is about models that
can represent complicated probability
distributions well beyond the kind of
everything's concentrated on one
output Sal learning is the puzzle tasks
um the there's been an interesting back
and forth initially on supervised
learning generative models were what
people were excited about then it became
all self-supervised learning for a while
and now it's swing back to more
generative models who knows where it'll
be next year um I think it's good to
know both of them
so why do we
care I think this might be the most
interesting motivation of them all I
hope you all know Jeff hon if you don't
please uh know him now Jeff Hinton is
essentially The Godfather of deep
learning he's been working on deep
learning since the
1970s had to wait for it to have a
breakthrough till 2012 so it's like a
40-year career of working on the thing
that he thought was going to be right
and after 40 years he proved himself
right because he was the one with his
students who had the big breakthrough on
image recognition with
alexnet now this is motivation for
unsupervised learning the brain has
about 10 to the power 14 synapses
synapses in the brain are connections
between neurons and they're essentially
the learnable part of the brain where
the neurons are connected or not is the
variation in what our brain is as a
little baby where nothing is really
wired up to know anything and then when
we're older we start knowing things 10
to the 14 synapsis and we only live for
about 10 to the 9
seconds so we have a lot more parameters
than
data this motivates the idea that we
must do a lot of unsupervised learning
since the perceptual input including Pro
perception is the only place we can get
10 the 5 dimensions of constraint per
second right because if we assume that
the brain is kind of meant to be fully
utilized um then we do need to get 10
the 5 essentially bits in some sense per
per second to fully utilize our brain
now there are other motivations why the
brain is so large it could be that a
larger
brain can learn faster than a smaller
brain even if not that many bits have to
be learned that's something Jeff has
also talked about I think both probably
have some truth to it but this is a very
clear sign that supervised learning is
not enough for how humans essentially
use their brains there's a lot more
going on Beyond supervised
learning Yan Lon similar thing need
tremendous amount of information to
build machines that have common sense
and
generalize um and I think this kind of
gets into another Trend that we've seen
recently in AI which is foundation
models Foundation models are train on
such a large amount of data that they
generalize much better than any models
before um it used to be you'd have a
model for let's say um recognizing the
sentiment of uh a paragraph is this a
positive or A negative review of a
product and you had a dedicated language
model to do that and it was better back
then to train a dedicated language model
for sentiment analysis than to train one
model to do everything but that's
changed Foundation models are trained on
all the data I'll perform the
specialized models now and I would argue
in some
sense that that's the closest we're
getting to Common Sense with current
machines is by training on such a wide
swath of data that somehow everything
starts to fall within distribution at
least a little bit so Yan Lon um
presented this cake now known as L cake
um at the at his nur's keynote in
2016 and the point he was making is that
um back in 2016 actually all the
excitement at nurs was about
reinforcement learning so he was trying
to make a point uh that people maybe
should be a little less excited about
reinforcement learning was part of his
point not not excited but maybe a little
less and pay more attention to
unsupervised learning
his point was that essentially you need
a lot of data only way to get a lot lot
of data is unsupervised learning so
that's the foundation of the Ki it's
most of the volume SL mass of the kick
the icing is the supervised learning and
then the Cherry is the reinforcement
learning it's pretty interesting if you
look at um chat GPT it's exactly this
model chat GPT is trained on the entire
internet to get the foundational
knowledge supervised fine tuning that's
the icing on the kick then r F
reinforcement from Human feedback that's
the Cherry it's l cake essentially
predicted um six years ahead of time how
AI would shape up into its at least
current most capable
form another way you might get motivated
for unsupervised learning is this notion
of Ideal intelligence so ideal
intelligence people argue is all about
compression finding all the patterns in
your data that's what it means to be
smart you understand all the patterns
that are
there so finding all patterns means
finding a short description of raw data
meaning low kog complexity so what is
comra
complexity com of complexity
says the size in some sense measured as
com of complexity of a certain data set
is the size of the shortest computer
program that can represent that data set
put it out as on it's output now the
simplest way to do it but that might not
be the winning uh size is to just store
the entire data set and just have a
program that says print and then it
prints out the entire data set so that's
that's a very simple program but it's
rarely going to be the one that wins but
if you had a completely random string
with no pattern in it that might be the
winning program that you could possibly
produce um to do that but for many real
world data sets um there's other ways to
describe the data that's more efficient
and com of complexity measures that by
the way the way to think of this in
neural net land is that you should think
of
the size of the neural net as
essentially the size of your program the
neural network is the program because
instead of writing code you're training
a neural network so the neural network
is the program and so here some's asking
what is the most compact neural net
Network that can regenerate my data and
that should be the one that understands
the data the best and hence U best at
let's say generalizing hopefully there
are some subtleties there by the way
smallest NE net doesn't need to mean
smallest number of parameters it could
mean something else it could mean that
you have low Precision parameters but
large number of parameters and maybe
that's a better way to represent things
than having higher Precision parameters
but less parameters um so keep that in
mind
shortest code length um in principle
should also allow for optimal inference
um and S of induction is kind of a bit
more focused on on that that side of
things um extensible to Optimal action
making agents which is called aixi so
aixi is essentially looking at this
notion that if you want to build an
agent that solves
problems what is the smallest agent I
can build that can solve these problems
and that's the counterpart of recreating
your data in unsupervised learning but
now in reinforcement
learning here not a motivation very
related in fact IL sis Chief scientist
of openai co-founder of open AI um
talked about this just about a half year
ago at the Science Institute here assume
we pre-train in an unsupervised way on
data distribution
D1 and then fine tune on a data
distribution D2 then then if D1 and D2
are
related compressing D2 conditioned on
already knowing D1 should be more
efficient than compressing D2 outright
the additional effort should be less
given the effort you've done before to
compress D1 if there's any kind of
relationship between them so
pre-training on D1 should allow you to
learn faster on D2 this is kind of like
a very let's say it's not a super ma
ially precise but it's an intuitive
argument for why unsupervised learning
should help when you later all you care
about is supervised learning all you
care about is labeling every pixel on
your self-driving car scene still UNS
supervised learning might be the right
thing to start with by the way these
kinds of motivation I
remember um early days of um early days
of of open AI when it was just 10 of us
um Ilia John Andre
uh couple of my students
myself back then supervised learning was
always winning like anything you cared
about supervis Lear was always winning
and we actually had to think hard about
these aspects to decide that we should
work on unsupervised learning part of
motivation was there's more data so
clearly that that's going to help but
the other part was people would say well
it doesn't matter because that data is
not what you want you just need to label
enough supervised data and you'll get
things done but our argument was things
like this is why we should still work on
unsupervised learning today that
argument is more mot it's empirical you
pre-train and then fine tune you get
better results um wasn't the case back
then when you went you started with
unsupervised as your
pre-training aside from theoretical
interests um deep enzed learning has
many powerful applications you can
generate novel data uh you can do
conditional
synthesis you can do compression with
it um by the way the compression hasn't
really been commercialized yet I still
wondering when that might happen cuz um
when we when we're seeing the electron
compression
effectively what is compression how much
can you compress a data set is based on
how good a model you have for the
probability distribution that
constitutes your data set and then the
bound is the entropy of that
distribution that's how much you can
compress your data and so if you have a
better model you should be able to
compress
better so far it turns out that maybe
these new Nets are kind of large and so
once you count off actually the comor of
complexity including the size of N Net
and the amount of inference required to
decode it hasn't been winning yet you
could imagine a future where if compute
chips become even larger and cheaper
that you have a massive neural network
decoding all the movies that you watch
and very little bits have to come over
the pipe because it can decode
efficiently and from a very highly
compressed representation compared to
what's possible
today improve any Downstream task by
doing pre-training un or
self-supervised production level impact
Google search powered by Bert was the
first one that's why I'm highlighting it
here I think that was the first real
production level impact of unsupervised
learning flexible building blocks for
other things some of the architectures
that were invented for UNS supervised
learning are now reused in reinforcement
learning in supervised learning
so a lot of reasons um you could be
interested in what we're going to cover
here so let me dive
into actually let's see how long are we
in yeah let's let's let's not take a
break right now let's keep going just a
little bit um this is part of where
generative model started at least for
image generation uh it was called Deep
Bel Nets back then it was a different
name um but it was the same kind of idea
you train a neural network a specific
type of neural network in this case that
has fallen out of favor and these were
some of the early results showing that
you can train this neural Nets to
generate images that look like the
images in your training set at the time
this was pretty surprising to
people it was still hard to correctly
classify cats and dogs at the time
because that didn't really happen till
imag net Alex net 2012 as the fact that
while people were still struggling to
have an image classifier for cats and
dogs other people were generating digits
it was pretty surprising that was
possible um the variation Auto encoder
kind of made one of the big steps
forward after neural networks broke
through in 2012 and we'll look a lot at
the vae couple lectures from
now um Gans by Ian Goodfellow and
collaborators in
2014 were the first sign that as this
Neal Nets are likely to generate
realistic images in the foreseeable
future until
Gans somehow if you look back at the vae
everything looks kind of smooth out and
that's just how these models tended to
be they try to predict things that are
on average kind of right but on average
being right is not exactly right it's
like if the answer is you know either
yes or no to a question saying something
in the middle is never going to be
correct um same thing here it's just
smoothing things out too much but Gan
started resolving that this still low
resolution that was just compute
limitation at the time exciting story
here by the way um Ian was uh having
drinks with friends in a bar in
Montreal and they just you know what do
you do when you're AI student you have
drinks you talk about AI um and they're
just like how is it possible that these
neuron Nets can create proper
images even a neuronet can see that
these images aren't sharp um and Ian's
like wait even if if NE can even see
this these pre previous images are not
that sharp I should just just use a NE
net to give feedback to the create
creation neet the Gen NE net and set up
a feedback loop and see what happens he
CED up the same night he started seeing
a real sign of life and then a little
later wrote the
paper interestingly um Gans well here's
another interesting backstory actually
Alec Ratford first author of this paper
this was the first time with the bedroom
data set here that Gans were showing
actual high quality images people said
this is not just a sign that this will
be possible soon this this now becoming
possible um Alec I believe um dropped
out of college to play with AI and had
some good success he wrote this paper
and then open I recruited him I remember
that we recruited him I was like okay he
did the best generative model to date
back in 2015 um and so um it was
interesting at the time that these
things were possible um just you know
you find the paper in archive and based
on that you decide to recruit
somebody Alec by the way was a great
recruit obviously because Alec Ratford
is the one who started the whole GPT um
uh sequence of Works had open ey gpt1
well gpt1 in some sense was was an lstm
but then gpt2 three all started with
Alec uh interesting story there uh he
actually let a model train while he was
away for a while and then it kept
improving it realized wait we've never
been training long enough clearly we
should be training much longer and that
also helped Inspire the much uh longer
training sessions um so sometimes say
did going away and not killing your
process is is uh the way to go
too from these are some images of uh
faces which we as humans tend to be very
sensitive to artifacts and faces so
obviously here we're seeing signs alive
but we don't yet see this as realistic
um super illusion Gans came soon
thereafter um Al EOS and his students
here did things with Gans that were very
entertaining you could essentially
recolor uh subjects and images this case
the horse uh becomes a a
zebra um and then deep mine did a very
large training the first very very large
Gan
training and so this was the first time
by this was
2018 um where Gans were showing very
realistic images now some of them in
between are not super realistic cuz it's
interpolating between different ones um
but you can see when it's not
interpolating it is
um is it playing
music so pretty amazing um at the time
people essentially thought this is it
you know Gans are the way to generate
images uh in the best possible way and
um a lot of iterations were done
especially Nvidia did a lot of work
scaling up even more getting even more
um impressive results over time time um
styan came out of Nvidia uh these faces
become kind of indistinguishable from
real human faces and that was uh also
2018 then something happened that was
kind of surprising in some sense uh even
though Gans were all the rage and
everybody thought this is it with this
is how we're going to solve image
Generation Um diffusion models came on
the scene you might wonder why even
bother coming up with diffusion models
at the time um the challenge people ran
into with Gans was that even though
everything was very
realistic it wasn't covering the entire
distribution that the data had so it was
focusing on specific modes of the
distribution rather than having great
coverage of the entire distribution and
so the open question at the time is can
you come up with a new approach or
improve Gans that's fine too but can you
come up with something that is both
generating realistic images and has good
coverage doesn't leave out a lot of the
um data effectively and so diffusion
models showed that you know clear sign
alive in this paper in 2020 and they're
also the models powering almost all the
image generation today so I'll just put
some fun examples at least some of the
ones that I find the most fun um all
done with diffusion models um these were
not in the original diffusion paper the
ones I show here are from doly from open
AI um a masterful oil painting a Persian
exotic cat discovering their astounding
crypto losses while checking their
phone why is this an interesting prompt
well it's interesting partially because
it's entertaining obviously but it's
also interesting
because it's targeting something that
would not be in the training data right
and if the AI in this case this
diffusion model can generate a good
response to this it means that it
understands something Beyond replicating
what's in the data it should understand
something about how to combine cats
with phones and a standing crypto losses
which probably means being not
particularly happy and here's what it
comes up
with then here's another one of my
favorites a Victorian man struggles with
his addiction to Tik
Tok same gist it's there some humor to
it there's also this notion that it's
not going to be in the data Victorian
man did not have access to Tik Tok that
was T years in England um nobody had
well anything like Tik Tok at the time
and here's what it comes up with it
actually gets it really well it's the
the guy is holding an alcohol flask that
some kind of addiction generally
speaking red cheeks looking pretty sad
looking at his phone and it's all said
in the Victorian
era here's another one of my favorites
Darth fader realizing he's forgotten to
add an attachment to the email
mail Darth Vader never forgot to add
attachments but we could imagine what it
would look like and again the model is
capable of doing this looks like a
business traveler sitting on the hotel
room bed firing off some emails before
going to dinner and then U making a
mistake these were all open eyes do
model um here's oh The Prompt should
have come first but um this one from
Google's imagine a photo of a shba Uno
dog with a backpack riding a bike is
wearing sunglasses and a beach hat and
it creates a photo realistic image in
this
case a lot of them have come since so
open eyes DOI and Google's imagine came
out first soon thereafter stable
diffusion came out um stability AI has
been hosting that mid Journey has been
building off of that on their Discord
servers um in fact the folks on the
Imagine team one of the key people on
the Imagine team team is Jonathan hoe
who was a PhD student here wrote a
diffusion models paper then went to
Google did this work as well as the
Imagine video work um and then she left
Google to start a company called
ideogram um because Google was not
putting its Ms out there it just became
frustrating for him to do this great
work and then everybody's like oh do is
so much fun mid journey is so much fun
he like AB built this amazing imagine
mall and nobody's having fun with it
it's just like behind closed doors at
Google and so he ideogram which is also
one of the top providers of text to
image right
now so in the uh remainder of today's
lecture we'll look at a few more um
pretty exciting kind of examples of
progress in UNS supervised learning over
the last few years Kevin will be
presenting those and then at the very
end I'll wrap up the class with the last
slide um one quick thing that come up
during the break um it turns out that
the Forum we use is um you can't self
sign up we have to add you it seems um
and so if you want to get access to us
you kind of need to start here if you're
already on the class roster already on
the weight list you should already be on
the Ed Forum but if you're not email us
here we can add you to the Forum and
then from there you can start finding
everything else because you can find the
class website and everything else we'll
post there um but yeah if you're stuck
getting started the whole process email
us here and then uh we'll help you get
going
okay cool yeah so for the remainder of
the lecture we're just going to kind of
go over some fun things that
unsupervised learning can do today so a
lot of what we looked in the past here
and then the last few sides are are
image based and and here's kind of one
thing where we try to go into a
different domain so wave net here um
from 2018 it kind of ask the question
okay we can generate images um what can
we do with with other domains and it
turns out okay we can actually generate
audio signals as well and and the method
they use here is actually pretty simple
to what we were doing back in the pixel
domain so these are diffusion models so
they're kind of from a bit later but
this wave net builds off uh pixel CNN
which we might cover in the in the
autoaggressive part but it basically
just predicts the audio step by step so
if you take the raw audio format predict
the next one condition on everything in
the past you get kind of a a generative
model of the entire audio framework and
so wavenet proves that okay if we do
this in the right scalable way this
works uh and of course these things are
getting better over time so this is
audio craft um comes out of meta uh from
2023 so just earlier uh this year or
last year and uh it's basically building
off the same technique so if we do auto
regressive prediction we can generate
the samples one by one and here um we we
use a few tricks so instead of
predicting things in the Raw audio space
like we're doing back here in the
wavenet in audio craft we first um first
we'll tokenize everything so this is
kind of a trick that we'll kind of see
recurring is that actually if you
tokenize things first U predicting is a
lot easier so tokenize everything first
here we tokenize for example text and
audio into the same space uh and then
you can just concatenate so text audio
comes after prct it all at once and you
get basically audio generation and here
they show okay we can do it for music we
can generate songs and we can do it for
things such as um other
sounds uh text to speech is also
something we can do with unsupervised
learning so I guess in this case it is
it is somewhat supervised and there are
some some labels we use to connect the
two but a lot of what's going on here
such as the embeddings and all these
things are are going on um in an
unsupervised way so this tacron work is
basically one of the one of the landmark
works that says okay we can take in text
do some processing on it and we get out
these these spectrograms which are
basically just ways of representing
audio uh and then we'll use this this
wavenet model so something built off
wavenet earlier to turn it into into a
raw audio file
uh and yeah these days the Texas speech
has gotten really good so there's this
um company called 11 Labs has been
making uh basically making these better
internally uh we can do things like
giving speech in in different styles so
we have different for example
personalities here uh and it turns out
that converting between Styles is also
pretty easy so it's kind of a it's a
tough problem to go from text directly
to sounds because actually the text
doesn't contain all the information need
to make a sound we we have things like
like intonation we have expressivity
that's that's not exactly all in the
sounds uh but if we do for example voice
conversions uh we can convert from like
one side to another this is something
fun that like some of you might have
seen in the past so like it gained
popularity last year but basically
people using these generators to to talk
in the voices of of other people so one
of the famous ones is these presidents
talking about something that they would
never actually talk about but it is
pretty
funny so that's kind of text to speech
and then video is also kind of this new
domain so I think video stuff is is just
starting to work um I know Wilson is
working on it some people are working on
it um but basically can we do can we do
generation in video space the same way
that generation in image image space is
working really well so here's some
examples using Gans so you know if we
just have data sets of videos we can
actually just predict or we can optimize
the the generative model over that using
the same Gan format that we use um back
in images uh and then there's also kind
of more methods based on diffusion model
so this this emu video uh does this kind
of stepbystep process so what it does is
uh this is actually text text video the
text is not shown but you can kind of
describe the scene first and then what
it does is like kind of the lesson learn
in this paper is you if you factorize a
distribution it it works a lot better so
what you do here is given the text first
predict the first frame and that's kind
of the whole image generation problem in
itself and then given the first frame
and the text let's just generate the
rest of the keyr and then let's generate
the in between frames and it turns out
just factorizing things that way works
really well we can get things that are
at least consistent I think consistency
in the videos is something that's still
kind of an unsolved problem I think
we're it's getting there things are
getting more consistent um as new works
come out but you can still you can still
see artifacts here where like this Frame
doesn't actually connect to to the other
frame
physically uh video poet so this is
another kind of concurrent is work
uh where they try to do the same problem
so from text to video uh and in video
poet they they take the same lesson that
happened back in the um the audio
generation where they say okay actually
let's just tokenize everything so the
same way that we do it in language
models we're going to tokenize images
into image tokens uh and then we have
our text tokens we have our image tokens
we can predict it auto regressively uh
and if you scale this L the right way we
start to get video generation that makes
sense so and I think these are pretty
interesting because they see the same
sort of scaling properties that we saw
back in images so like these videos
obviously are not real like the pen is
pling cards this is not actually in the
data distribution uh but we have the
nice kind of interpolation that that we
proved earlier in image space now are
they're applying to other domains and in
image and sounds as well we're able to
generate for example like songs that are
played you know modern songs played with
a classical instrument for example which
aren't actually in the data set but we
can guess what they might
sound and and there's kind of some some
applications for these things outside of
just generating videos like these videos
here are cool but it's kind of hard to
think of you know what are we actually
going to use it for well one answer is
if we can simulate the world this
actually gives us a nice thing if we
want to do control so if we want to for
example get a robot to to plan to
imagine what would happen if I tried to
do a certain thing well if we have a
good video simulation of the world we
can actually just roll that out we don't
have to run the experiment in real life
but we can run it in a simul
so as um as these models get better and
better we're going to start seeing more
Downstream applications of them so the
video thing is trained you know in an
unsupervised way this is kind of the
pre-training where the pre-training goes
into the world model and then later we
can do for example reinforcement
learning or planning on top of these
mods uh and then there's a text link so
we we'll go into this I won't go into it
in too much because I think the language
modeling we're going to have a lecture
on it later um and I don't want to get
too much into language mod specific
stuff but language models are a form of
unsupervised learning and this is kind
of character RNN um Andre carpy wrote
this little blog post back in 2015 where
where he said okay what if we have an
RNN um a recurrent Network that just
predicts each character after another
and this is before um you know we kind
of knew that these things would scale
very well but we could still generate
pretty fun things so some stories for
example that that are that are made up
here um and the the Character level rnns
were actually pretty powerful in that
you could train them on things that are
not entirely language or natural
language for example we can generate
latch text we can generate text uh and
and this is a lesson that we'll see in
in language modeling at least um that
some people like to say that language
contains a lot more than just words it
contains kind of some some patterns of
thought there's arguments that language
models can can serve as Foundation
models or things that are not just
language and here is kind of just some
very early results that okay we can
generate math we can generate things uh
I don't know if this math actually makes
sense it might be making it up but it it
it looks right from a
distance uh and then so yeah gpd2 kind
of the open ai's next attempt that at
scaling these models up showed that uh
these prompts so so I think the main the
main kind of innovation that came out of
gpd2 is that with the right prompting
you can actually get these Foundation
models or these like large unsupervised
models to do the things we want them to
do whereas you know in the early kind of
generate math or generate text we didn't
really know how to guide them it can
generate from the distribution of text
that's trained on but we don't know how
to get it to do exactly what we want uh
and GPT to kind of showed that you can
just tell it what to do and it's kind of
this the theme we'll see a little bit
later is that there's kind of a shift
from having to train early on these like
supervised models that everything is
trained specifically on what we want it
versus okay we can just train these
these giant
distributions um and as long as we
constrain it by providing some some
constraints at the top like the prompt
what comes after kind of naturally has
to follow certain instructions so gpd2
is able to do some nice things like
generate
stories and um it can fight against you
I think this is saying yeah recycling is
not good for the world don't really want
to be saying this but it
can uh and then so this is chat gbt so
gpd2 this was around in 2019 since then
the models have scaled up um even larger
although the the principles are
essentially the same uh but we can kind
of see why it's so powerful to to learn
these UNS supervised models because the
same kind of lesson we got here where we
can do a little bit of prompting uh to
get what we want out uh continues to
improve the better our distribution
matches so with language models today
you can actually do things like for
example ask it for Json output and it
can give you nice structured files and
and this is kind of opening up a lot of
avenues for like okay we can use this to
generate things that are readable by
computers not necessarily only by
humans uh another kind of nice thing
that language models can do today is is
this long form summarization so as um
the context lengths go up so as as the
length of text that the models can
actually handle in memory goes up uh we
can start to do kind of more
understanding based tests so back in
gpd2 the prompts were usually like a
sentence long and then most of the
output comes from here and that's
essentially because the limit of the
model was was pretty small like you
couldn't really go much longer than this
uh but now it's cut off over there but
there's a big article about for example
what unsupervised learning is and the
models can actually just synthesize it
so we're we're we're entering a stage
where the models themselves can be
conditioned in these very like high high
bit ways uh even if the output itself is
is little
bit uh and yeah these models uh are all
available for use so you can try it I'm
sure many of you have heard heard of
these these things before they've been
all over around but uh yeah things
things are escaping and and they're
working so yeah a little bit about
compression as well so this is paper
from I
think 2017 if this is the same um but
but basically it's it's showing how how
generative models can be used as
compression and again we'll have a
lecture on this later but the basic idea
is if we look at actual kind of hand
handwritten compression methods like
jpeg they assume some form about the the
natural image space so jpeg assumes that
pixels are naturally smooth and if you
assume this we can turn pix we can turn
images into less less bits than if we
assume nothing and compression using a
generative
model it's basically doing the same
thing but instead of assuming this kind
of natural image distribution in terms
of let's say smoothness or in terms of
neighbors we just learn it from data and
so we say okay if all we care about our
images that come from let's say the the
million images in in this training Set
uh I only need you know a smaller number
of bits because I'm assuming
okay I won't have images of noise or of
Graphics if it's a 3D data set and so we
can get compression numbers that are
better because we make stricter
assumptions and kind of one yeah one one
argument against these models some of
them are are lossy I mean jpeg is
already lossy to begin with and for a
lot of applications it's perfectly fine
if it's lossy like all video codecs are
essentially lossy because it doesn't
make sense to encode all of that most
frames are the same we can get if your
YouTube video doesn't load you'll see
things like this um but if we assume
like an even
stricter um constraint on the
distribution we can get things like this
where the same number of bits gives you
a much crisper image because we kind of
learned what what images are likely and
which ones
are um things in 3D are also working so
this is a paper from 2020 that uses
Nerfs so Nerfs are this this way of
representing a 3D image as kind
implicitly as the outut of a neural
network uh and the first NERF paper just
trained them um by taking videos
potentially of one object and then this
paper which is I think it's like it's
either a gan based Nerf or or a vae
based Nerf but it says okay actually if
we have a representation of a 3D model
um let's just learn that distribution
let's learn to generate things and so
here we have models of face like like a
car a chair and because these models are
actually 3D models you can move the
camera around and see them from
different angles and
again a lot of the the power of these
methods comes from the fact that they
are unsupervised you don't need labels
we don't actually even need the the 3D
models themselves in some cases as long
as you have pictures of them it's enough
to reconstruct the model itself a
question the fora model how
youc like is a hyperarch of like see
which l
or yeah it's a great question and I
don't know the answer off my head uh I I
I could make a guess but I think think
you would you would get the correct
answer reading the work here jump in for
a moment so for some gen models it's a
bit harder to measure but for the ones
that optimize
likelihood it's literally the likelihood
so the log average log loss directly
translates into bits now you might have
to apply a factor log two to it to get
it in bits rather than in Nats um but
it's the same metric um just because in
optimal compression assuming you use
optimal comp compression you get to
compress your data down to the entropy
of the distribution that's the number of
bits you need and that corresponds to
the average log prop of all your data
points entropy is average log prop and
so your Lo average log prop is exactly
what's being measured there it's
measured in and so bits per bite here
means average log prop per bite an image
will have a red bite a green bite and a
blue bite to resent the three colors at
each location and so it's measuring
what's the average log
prop per image and then normalizing it
by the number of bytes that are in the
image to get you this
number uh yeah so basically that's
that's one application of these models
do some compression and and like Peter
said earlier if you actually look at the
the how to measure the compression it it
requires an optimal encoder and an
optimal decoder so that kind of
motivates the fact that the more
powerful your model is the better you
should be able to actually Reach This
bound on the how how you can compress a
data set yeah and the optimal since the
optimal compressor is not actually
possible don't they usually use the
normalized compression distance which
comes from
the right so I guess yeah one way you
could view these these are all lower
bounds like we don't know the true
compression of the data set because we
don't know if our encoder or decoder are
optimal um I guess you can say that
they're like Optimal is in terms of if
your if your com complexity is how many
parameters your your network is this is
it's not the best actually you can get
in that parameter C because we're
training them there could be a better
solution in that parameter space but
it's it's what we get if we try to push
as hard as we can on those
bounds um yeah so 3D generation it's
also getting better so that this is from
2020 this is what we can do in 2022 now
again similar similar techniques uh
where we kind of
assume and and the interesting thing
about 3D is we can actually assume even
more it's kind of even more unsupervised
than than 2D images because in 2D images
we we have data sets of 2D images in 3D
sometimes we don't even have data sets
of 3D models all we have are our 2D
pictures of the world but we can assume
certain things about them like if you
take kind of a few pictures of of an
object from different perspectives we
know that light reflects in certain ways
and and there's kind of one model that
actually results in these views and by
writing down little things like this we
can actually generate models even though
we don't have that data so it's kind of
we have one assumption and then we can
do our our unsupervised stuff under this
assumption uh and finally like there
there's some domains that are also less
visual but arguably
more more important Alpha fold as one of
them um figured out how to do
essentially protein prediction uh and
here there is I think there is some
supervision at the end but a lot of the
power comes from this kind of
unsupervised representation learing that
happens in the protein space before
this um yeah and then so maybe what came
before that was okay here here are some
cool applications of what we can do with
unsupervised learning um and now it's
like a bit of motivation for why
unsupervised learning is important um if
you even if you have a specific problem
you want to solve uh sometimes it's
better to still do large scale
pre-training before uh and and this is
from the foundation models paper uh from
Stanford but a lot of the field these
days is moving to this this setting
where we do this large scale
unsupervised pre-training and then we do
adaptation to what we actually care
about and the form of adaptation can
take many forms it can be fine-tuning
the network it can be prom thing it
could even be for example zero shot or
or some something few shot but this sort
of Paradigm has has kind of this is a
big shift from maybe 10 years ago five
years ago um this is now kind of what
what uh seems to be working at least in
terms of generalizing to some real
problems and so we we'll show some
examples of of how this pre-train
formulation has come out so this is from
the GPT paper I believe and it shows
that okay we have these language models
we can actually they just do sentiment
detection I think this is either with a
linear header or some sort of small
adaptation um it knows how to do sentim
detection off the
bat and a lot of things now build off
these things where okay we we example
pre-train with with a birt loss or we'll
see later a GPT loss and then they they
solve these benchmarks at a much higher
rate so we'll see for example the way we
actually measure and this is in language
model space how good a language model is
is actually pretty it's pretty rric
there's all these different kinds of
things like like code generation reading
comprehension maybe solving exams and
it's really showing the point that the
unsupervised learning on these models
can then solve like all these random
domains that it's not actually
specifically trained to be able to
do uh and and there's this so prompting
is kind of a we won't go too much into
it but it's it's also this this
adaptation method where there's a lot of
interesting things like strategies now
about how to extract what we want out of
the big model so we we know that these
models have all these this knowledge
ingested we know that at some level they
theyve represented them correctly or
represented them to a really nice degree
and then the question is just how to get
it out and there's some there's some
messy ones um this is from open eyes
guide and and the fact that they have
the guide on there shows that this is
something that people are at least
thinking a lot
about and finally we we'll see the same
thing in Vision so this is this is from
kind of I think this is from 2018 but
this is this is using contrastive
learning so another unsupervised method
and it's showing that the performance
when we transfer from unlabeled data
even on these tasks that have
traditionally been been using supervised
data uh they're still pretty good
and uh for example mass auto encod which
comes out in 2021 also shows results on
on these data sets which are
traditionally um you can train a
supervised method on it it turns out if
you pre-train this is big Auto encoder
on a lot of data it works better
here uh and okay so this is the last
slide and it's just an overview of all
the stuff before but I think one one
kind of nice motivating thing about
about UNS supervis learning is it seems
like the method that scales the best as
as data comes in like we saw the laon's
cake earlier where where most of the
volume is is on supervised learning and
that's because it's just so much easier
to collect this raw data than to have
human labels and human labels they can
be wrong they can be they can be
multimodal they can have all sorts of
weird
properties um whereas the fact that
essentially the same methods such as
like Auto aggressiveness or or things
we'll learn later in the class can solve
all these different domains should
should tell something about um that
there's something correct about how
we're doing these
things thank you
Kevin um I want to quickly highlight one
thing that uh we went over just a little
fast this slide here this is from
2020 and I want to highlight the thing
on the right here there was a bet
between two professors here alosa EOS
and jender Malik and it the formal
version of the BET says if by the first
day of autumn of 2015 a method will
exist that can match or beat the
performance of rcnn on Pascal vocc
detection so detection task rather than
classification without use of any extra
human annotation i
s uh so on surise pre-training
effectively Mr Malik promises to buy Mr
EOS One galat Two Scoops one chocolate
one vanilla so what was going on here
alosa EOS challenged the ten and said I
think un survis learning will win and
jener said well let's make it bet around
it you tell me when it's going to win
clear alosa was optimistic he put it on
autumn 2015 it didn't happen until this
paper here the CPC V2 paper which was
Autumn 2020 um so
um yeah uh five year five years later
but it did happen and I think it's kind
of interesting to see some of these
things play out where uh for the longest
time the thing that was
winning there were actually other things
people already thinking about that you
could project into the future would be
the ones winning out in the long run
we're just not there we need to figure
out some details we need to figure out
scale and once it's figured out it'll
actually uh be better than what is the
current way of doing things so chender I
got the gelato from alosa in this case
but um in the long run alosia was was
right I guess that Unis learning is a
more powerful
pre-train so in summary un learning is
actually rapidly advancing as a field
thanks to compute for sure deep learning
engineering practice becoming better
data sets and these days lots of people
working on it it's not just an academic
interest topic anymore it used to be but
definitely not anymore today language
modeling image generation Vision
language multimodal pre-training are all
working really well and have production
level impact with the bird one for
Google search having been the first one
but obviously many more
now what is true now may not be true
even a year from now and I'll give you
two examples just to make this concrete
um example one we just talked about self
supervised pre-training was way worse
than supervis and computer vision tasks
like detection segmentation until
actually so turns out was full 2019 when
CPC V2 came out and now it's better
example two representational inform
Vision through masking didn't work
people said why not just mask like in in
language you just mask things out
nothing worked um or nothing worked all
that well until King her and his
collaborators um made it work in
November
2021 and the word on the street was
masking doesn't work in
Vision doesn't work but turns out now
it's what works the best so these things
are all in flux and that's one of the
things I want you to keep in mind I
would love to see final projects where
you challenge some of the common wisdoms
of today and you ideally you have a
reason for it right maybe the reason
here could have been well if it works
for language
why can it not at least work reasonably
well for vision maybe it's not going to
be the best but at least it should be
reasonably well what was the key thing
King did that nobody else did well first
he's a very good experimenter so he
iterated over many things he's he's the
best but then What timly mattered is he
masked out 80 90% of the image and turns
out that was key and before that people
were masking out 10
20% and masking out 10 20% the task
turns out too easy remember the early
slide Jeff in saying the brain must be
doing a lot of work with having you know
10 to the five synapses available per
second to be trained um well King effect
said let's put the N work make it work
harder than just refilling back in 10
20% make it somehow create the 90% that
you left out and all of a sudden results
are great um Vision Transformer
architecture helps with making masking
easier to do in your training and hence
it also helped in kind of making this
possible um but the combination factors
I think the biggest one timly
conceptually is masking way more than
anybody had ever done
before um autoagressive models flows
Vees Gans diffusion models um the ones
we'll cover in the first five weeks of
class I think they still have
significant room for surprising
capabilities meaning that maybe if you
scale it up in a domain where people
haven't done it yet um maybe video which
is still a very early domain for people
to apply is too maybe robotics which is
still early going biodata other Sciences
data even just applying the current
ideas can likely give very surprising uh
results so it's a great time to work
with them on them um but also think the
core of un surprise learning might still
have some major Innovations ahead um the
example I gave earlier lost offering in
2020 which is a while ago now but back
then we had no lecture on diffusion
models because we hadn't written the
denoising diffusion paric models paper
yet and and at the time people thought
of Gans as the thing that is the best at
image generation and since then it's
obviously changed I think more changes
could be ahead and so I really challenge
you to think hard about all these
methods that we'll be presenting and um
see if you can somehow find a way to to
improve them by thinking very hard about
what how they sit up and I think often
and of course I'll try to give more
color when we're get into specific ones
but often the devils in details in these
things something is presented the big
picture makes sense it seems like yeah
this is going to be the best and maybe
it's even the best as it's presented but
then you go to the specifics of How It's
actually written out in the equations
and actually there's already a bit of a
gap from the motivation to what the
equations actually have and then maybe
the implementation introduces another
Gap because exactly the math is not
what's being implemented and so there's
all these gaps that could come along the
way where you could see an opportunity
to make things better and maybe invent
the Next Generation or next iteration of
these of these models that would be a
pretty great outcome if that could
happen uh from this class all right
that's it for today thank you and uh see
you all next
week